la saison des foires au- vent d'octobre
bass son plan et un viticulteur dénonce
un marché gris et oui ce viticulteur
installé à saint-nicola de Bourgueil
refuse que ces vins soient vendus par la
grande distribution et pourtant ces
bouteilles sont en bonne place dans les
rayons d'une foireovin d'un hypermarché
de la ville au dame rien d'illégal mais
une pratique qui met ce producteur en
colère il parle d'une concurrence
déloyales avec les cavistes avec
lesquels il a choisi de travailler il
serait une dizaine de viticulteur
concerné Faustine
luno surprise pour Sébastien David ce
vigneron de Saint-Nicolas de Bourgueil a
choisi de ne pas vendre ses bouteilles
en grande surface pourtant la semaine
dernière il a retrouvé deux de ses cuvés
en vente sur le stand de l'espace foire
auin de trois supermarchés de magasins
Lecler en Bretagne ainsi que celui de la
ville au dame donc la CUV CF
2018 et puis on a aussi du kzako ce sont
des commerciaux qui qui m'ont appelé en
me disant euh bon qu' est du marché gris
on en entend souvent parler mais là
c'est des vins qui sont vendus moins
cher que dans le commerce habituel à qui
je travaille là on voit sur les kesako
sont acheté à 18 € alors qu'elles
sontquement en prix courant à 18,50 et
les CF surtout sont à 24 € alors que le
prix constaté couramment est de 26 €.
pour avoir une trace Sébastien David a
racheté une partie de la trentaine des
bouteilles exposées afin de pousser un
coup de gueule sur les réseaux sociaux
aujourd'hui je suis sur le parking du
Leclerc et je suis venu acheter des vins
à moi par principe je vends pas dans les
grandes surfaces ces bouteilles sont
donc arrivées là via un intermédiaire de
la vente grise comme il l'appelle une
pratique légale mais qui pose problème
selon lui sur TikTok les gens m'ont dit
bah oui mais tu les as vendu tu les tu
as été payé bah oui j'ai été payé mais
c'est la concurrence desloyales moi je
je vends à des gens qui portent conseil
qui amènent du Conseil des cavistes des
restaurateurs des baravin alors que là
ils m'ont appelé et clairement ils m'ont
dit bon benah si ça continue on arrête
de travailler avec toi déjà C cavist ont
préféré arrêter de vendre son vin
conséquence moins 5000 € de chiffre
d'affaires sur les 50000 qu'il réalise
en indrloire et il n'est pas le seul
dans ce cas neuf vignerons du valde
Loire seraient concerné au Leclerc de la
ville au dame nous on veut lever le
secret des affaires ce qu'on veut c'est
savoir qui pratique ça après moi je ne
vendrai pas aux personnes qui revendent
c'est tout les producteurs on donc
entamé une procédure auprès du tribunal
de commerce pour tenter de pousser
Leclerc à dévoiler l'identité du ou des
intermédiaires qui leur ont vendu ses
bouteilles malgré nos sollicitations
l'enseigne n'a pas souhaité
répondre